[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everybody.
Welcome back to the
Data Science Hangout,
hope everyone's
having a great week
for anybody joining us for their
very first time today, welcome.
This is actually our
second-to-last Data Science
Hangout for 2022.
So thank you to everybody who's
been with us this whole year
as well.
This is an open space for the
whole data science community
to connect and chat about
data science leadership,
questions you're
facing, and getting
to learn about what's going on
in the world of data science
and getting a view into
different industries
and use cases.
We share the recordings of these
sessions to our Posit YouTube,
so you can always go
back and rewatch or find
helpful resources.
And sorry, I am
three weeks behind.
But I will do that this
week and update them.
Together, we're all
dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment
for everybody.
No matter what industry or
background or experience
you have, we want to
hear from everybody.
So there's always three ways
that you can ask questions
and also to provide
your own perspective.
It doesn't have to
be just a question.
You can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom,
and I'll be on
the lookout there.
You can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to put a
little star next to it
if you want me to read
it out loud instead.
Maybe you're in a coffee
shop or something.
And then third, we
also have a Slido link,
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
I will mention too,
if you want to connect
with people after the fact,
we do have our LinkedIn group
for the hangout.
I know right now not too much
conversation goes on in there,
but we don't love to create
that space where you can easily
find each other.
You do have to manually turn
on notifications in that group,
so that might be part of it.
But I am so happy to be
joined by my cohost for today
and our friend from the Data
Science Hangout, Javier Orraca
Deatcu, lead machine-learning
engineer at Centene now
congrats on the new role
And Javier I'd love to have
you reintroduce yourself
because I know you've met a lot
of us from past weeks as well,
and share a little bit about
your role and the company
now and maybe something you like
to do in your free time too.
Thanks, Rachael.
Yeah, and it's great to be here.
This has been--
I've told many
people this, I really
do mean it-- this has
been my favorite standing
meeting for the last
year and a half or so.
So I feel like you've been
doing an awesome job, Rachael.
And I love this--
Thank you.
JAVIER ORRACA-DEATCU:
--platform for knowledge sharing
and whatnot.
Yeah, my name is Javier Orraca.
I've been around the
finance corporate, finance,
and data science world
for 15-plus years.
I spent a lot of my
career in consulting,
doing different types
of financial modeling
around valuation work, different
types of economic studies,
like economic
obsolescence studies,
functional obsolescence studies,
some tax optimization type
work.
And in those days, I
was mostly using Excel.
We would do some
SQL or SQL work,
but it was pretty minimal.
Whenever we were doing
that, I was actually
using Microsoft Access.
I feel like that's
not really a tool
used nowadays, but at least at
the time, when we were working
with hundreds of thousands
or millions of records,
it was much easier to do
the same types of group buys
and summations that we were
doing in Excel and for bigger
data using Access.
So I went back to grad school.
I really wanted to
get into data science.
It was kind of a buzzword.
I was reading all about
predictive analytics
without really knowing what
it was or what it meant.
But it excited me.
I wanted to really
get my hands on that
and understand how I can take
the forecasting or modeling
skills that I had, taking
it to the next level
so that I could start trying
to automate some of my work
or some of the reporting
that I'm doing.
So I went back to grad school.
And yeah, when I got out of
grad school, I joined Centene.
I was with them for
about two years.
I quit to go work for an
e-commerce startup for about
a year, and I just recently
returned to Centene.
I'm on week two in a
new org, so bear with me
if I can't answer all the
questions about my work.
But yeah, here at Centene, I'm a
lead machine learning engineer.
I'm part of a scrum team
that is a joint effort
with different data
scientists and data engineers.
And we're partnering with
our business stakeholders
and really taking these high-ROI
predictive-modeling concepts
and putting them
into production.
Yeah, something I
like to do for fun,
I love playing board games.
I feel like I spend way too
much of my free time reading
about developments in the R
world or Python developments.
I mean, I enjoy it.
A lot of times, I'm just reading
about the stuff, not really
even applying it through
code or anything,
just trying to keep up with all
the trends that are happening.
And yeah, that's a
little bit about me.
Thank you.
I have to ask, what's
your favorite board game?
In terms of being able
to explain it to friends
or play it quickly,
I love Splendor.
It's a card game.
It's two to four players.
Especially if the people
you're playing it with
have had a few repetitions,
it's a really fun, quick game.
Yeah, it's great.
Thank you.
I'll have to check it out.
OK, I see the questions are
coming in right off the bat,
so you don't even need me
for the first minute here.
So somebody asked
anonymously, when
is machine learning
appropriate or necessary?
So I come from a
heavy Excel background.
So I will caveat my
response by saying
my views might be a little
more nuanced than someone
may be coming from a CS
background or someone--
especially nowadays,
I feel like people
graduating from undergrad and
going into master's programs
or diving straight into machine
learning, which is awesome.
But I will say there is
a lot of reporting or KPI
creation or evaluating different
KPIs that doesn't require
machine learning and that is
also high value, because it
helps the business
track whether or not
some different product
or program is successful.
Where, machine
learning can be used
for inference or prediction.
And I feel like
both kind of sides
of this machine-learning
equation
add a lot of value
for different reasons.
When it gets to
prediction, I'd say
this is where you
really want to make
an intervention of
some sort, or you
want to focus on a subset
of your overall customers
or consumers and either
give value to them
or help the business maybe by
mitigating the risk of churn.
There's just a lot of reasons.
I'm not giving a
great answer here,
but-- and I'm happy
to give more detail.
But if that
individual, if you're
willing to submit another
anonymous question
or something, I'm happy
to dive further into that.
Thank you.
And Bill, I see you just put
a question into the chat.
Do you want to jump in next?
I'll start reading and
then you can jump in
if you want to add
any context too.
But bill asks, how big is
your team at your new--
wait, hold on.
How big is your team at your
new job and maybe break down
by roles use of R and/or
Python is more used in--
hold on, sorry.
I need to--
No, actually, I see--
--break down the
question a little bit.
Or do people still
try to develop new
or run old models using Excel?
Yeah, that's a good question.
Oh, Bill, was that you?
Can you hear me?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yes, we can.
There you are.
OK, yeah.
So I ask because I work
at a biotech company.
And some guy was giving
this presentation
of this fancy model about
drug pricing prediction
and all this kind of stuff.
And I said, oh, well
do you use SAS's addon
product that costs mega dollars
or, what's this done in?
And he said VBA.
And I didn't quite understand
because he has an accent
to me, an American.
And I said VBA? and he
said yeah, it's VBA.
So anyway, that's
one of the things
that prompts what
you're talking,
as well as your prior
discussion of your experience.
Yeah, so that's a
really good question.
And again, my Excel
experience is nuanced.
I would say, let's
say 90% of people
using Excel are using
it as a big calculator.
Everything's sort of ad
hoc, just thrown together.
Maybe they're
using pivot tables.
But there's no real modeling
workflow to their Excel work.
Then you have maybe 10% of
people that are actually
using Excel in a more advanced
way, where they actually
have an inputs and
assumptions tab, which is just
straight-up text explaining
the purpose of the model
and what's going to happen
in the subsequent tabs.
And you go from your records--
maybe one tab is just
straight tabular data, names
or identifiers on the
left and then a bunch
of different calculations
on the right.
And then going left to
right or right to left,
you get to summaries that are
actually consumable for leaders
in the business.
And then there's probably
0.1% of Excel users
that are using it in
a pretty advanced way,
whether it's logistic
regressions or different types
of linear regressions.
You could do a lot of
Monte Carlo simulations.
There's a lot you can do.
When you start feeling
like the GUI itself isn't
sufficient enough,
VBA, or Visual Basic,
it's a programming language that
plays hand in hand with Excel.
And you can actually do
a lot with automating
the workflow, or the sequence
of calculations or group buys
or whatever, with VBA in Excel.
I will say, that is not
typical of Excel users.
It's also very limiting.
Because with more open-source
programming languages,
not only with the
languages themselves
but with all the
libraries that are
available for these
languages, there's
just so much development
happening on a daily basis.
And I feel like for what you
described, while it could
potentially be done in VBA if
you wanted to scale something
that is consumable for
that business organization
or for other data
analysts or business
analysts at your
company, you probably
want to take the results
of those findings
and push them into some data
warehouse or something that,
again, is consumable to
a larger organization.
And in order to
do that, you need
to figure out, OK, well where
is this code going to live?
When is it going
to be refreshed?
Is it going to be retrained?
How is it going to be retrained?
What systems are going to help
us take this overall logic
and put it into a production
setting so that me, as a data
analyst or a business
leader, can just
access some table
on a data warehouse
and see the results I
want to see very quickly
and know that they're
updated at any point in time?
That's where I feel like
moving towards Python or R
opens your world
of possibilities
within the context of
automation and machine learning.
I don't know.
Bill, does that
answer your question?
Oh, we don't hear you.
Yeah, sort of, kind of.
So, again, I don't know
how big your company is.
And I don't know--
so there's always challenges.
One of those challenges,
you're talking about scaling
and having an infrastructure.
Well, in a lot of companies
I'm familiar with,
that means that
you bump into IT.
And IT-- I also work at
a regulated industry.
And so it SEEMS to be
the regulator-- like,
they like to they like to
squash the kind of thing
that you're talking about, even
though it totally makes sense
to me and other people
in the business thing.
But then they're worried
about people having
too much access to stuff.
Yeah, that's--
BILL MARTIN: I find
myself rambling.
And I think the main thing,
I just wanted to know,
so you come back
to this new place.
Do you have the
tools to do this?
And are you making an impact?
Or are other people still
on their own computers
doing Excel and
being happy and being
able to present a report
every few weeks to somebody
who pats them on the back
and says, hey, great?
OK.
So there's 70-plus
thousand people at Centene.
It's a massive company.
I think they're like,
a Fortune 26 company.
You really don't know the
name because, by design,
compared to the other
health insurance carriers,
they wanted to have kind of a
portfolio management company
and then each state that we
operate in has their own brand.
With that, the majority
of our analysts,
and probably data scientists
and biostatisticians,
work for the brands doing
plan-specific analyzes.
Where I'm at now is kind
of the corporate group.
And we partner with
stakeholders in the business
at different operating units or
we partner with idea generators
that want, that
have a business use
case that can be scaled for
the entirety of our business,
not just one plan.
From that perspective,
I think there
are some differences between--
I roll up into IT now.
And I definitely
sympathize with you.
Because when I was
previously at Centene,
I was actually working
for Health Net, which
is one of the state plans.
And there's a lot that I wanted
to do to put into production,
but there's so much
sensitive data in production
that corporate sort of helps
manage the whole process
of getting a model into
an actual production
setting, a model or a Shiny
app or something like this.
So you can do a lot as a
data scientist in a business
org in the development
and test environments
that are out there.
But when it gets to
production, then there
is somewhat of a handoff
in ownership, if you will,
or responsibility of getting
that code into a production
setting.
And that's where
there's a handshake
or pass off between
the business scientists
and then the corporate
data science team.
And there's 70,000 people.
We have an ongoing
chat of about 500
data analysts and
data scientists.
There's different, again,
clinical informatics people
and biostatisticians.
And there's a lot of very
interesting, niche work
going on.
But the one thing that I really
love about this organization
is the knowledge sharing.
There's a lot of that
that happens organically.
I love that there's not a lot
of shame in asking questions.
It's encouraged.
If you don't know something,
go ahead and ask it.
I have no shame when it comes
to asking people for help.
But at the same time, on
the flip side of this,
if someone comes to
me, I'm definitely
going to try and make
some time to help
this individual
with their problems
just to kind of
balance it all out.
Absolutely.
And I always love seeing in
the chat everybody commenting
in on what they're experiencing
in their organizations too.
And, Ness, I love to hear
what you're doing there too.
That's great.
I see, Eric, you had
asked a question a bit
earlier in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah.
It's great to have you,
Javier on the hangout.
As part of my organization
and the group I'm in,
I would say we're
kind of growing
into getting AI and ML more
entrenched in some of our work.
But leadership will hear all the
positive buzz from various tech
sectors and they say,
we want to use ML.
But what I want
your perspective on,
if you could share
any insights, is,
how do you approach finding best
use cases to use the algorithms
without going down potentially
dead ends or making sure
that leadership
understands that ML is not
going to magically be the
perfect solution for every use
case?
I don't know if
that makes sense.
Yeah, for sure.
I would say-- and I'm
new to this process.
Because, again, I was a
one-off data scientist
in a business org prior to
joining this corporate team.
And so I'm still learning about
all our systems and everything
that's available.
But one aspect of
this team's work,
which I think could be
applicable at other companies,
is to have a really
structured intake process.
For people that have new--
everyone's excited
about ML and AI.
But there should be some sort
of detailed or an educated
guesstimate of ROI
for the projects
that people want to put in.
And that's really hard to do,
even for experienced developers
and data scientists.
So I would say if
you don't already
have some type of intake
process or something
like this, where your
business stakeholders that
might have ideas can
come in and request
some type of company-wide,
Eli Lilly wide project
that, as part of that
submission or as part
of a conversation,
that your team has with
them is to really try and
quantitatively determine
what the benefit would be.
I think that is going
to go a really far way--
I'm still learning about
our whole intake process.
But a lot of my
Health Net peers,
now that they know that
I'm back are like, hey,
can we partner with this?
Can we partner it with this?
And I'm like, there
is sort of a--
we are trying to prioritize
the highest-ROI projects,
and there is an
official intake program.
So I'm pretty much just sending
them information on, hey,
here's the forms.
Please populate them.
And yeah, that seems
to have helped a lot
or helped this team scale
out their models a lot
and prioritize which models to
actually put into production.
I hope that answers
your question, Eric.
Oh, that's very helpful.
And there are
certainly pockets where
we do have some of
those things in place
for more general project ideas
or more general initiatives.
But yeah, it's
growing, the ML case
in certain parts of the
business where that just has not
been implemented at all.
We're trying to
find the best ways.
But that's good
advice, nonetheless.
I really like the--
oh, you go ahead.
I was just going to tell Eric
because, for those of you who
don't know, he has
an awesome podcast
and he runs the Shiny
Developer Series,
another amazing resource.
I just wanted to comment
that now that I'm
in this corporate team,
there's a lot that some
of my old colleagues that
I'd work with closely,
I wouldn't actually
recommend them
to submit a use case for us.
Because their problem is so
brand- or problem-specific.
It's not something
that can be scaled.
I notice-- I'm still
taking trainings and stuff,
so excuse me for not knowing
everything about the org now.
But before I left, Shiny
was becoming really popular.
People loved seeing what
a Shiny app could do.
I would say that I'm like
actively telling people
who have no R experience but
have heavy Excel experience,
for certain dashboards they
envision in Shiny that, maybe
a Power BI or just Excel
dashboard is the way to go.
Because they'll be able to get
what they want much faster.
The overhead to design this is--
making their project
a Shiny app is almost
unnecessary from what I see.
I love Shiny, but I think even
for finance orgs or actuaries
or people that are doing
a lot of maybe heavier
analysis in Excel, where
you want to convince them
that, hey, Shiny might
be the best place for you
is when they're trying to
get into scenario testing
or machine learning
or basic things.
They've got two million
records that they've somehow
hodgepodged together in Excel.
But when they make different
selections in an Excel
dashboard, it takes three
minutes for the dashboard
to re-render.
That's a good use case
to put it into Shiny,
because that three
minutes is now
all of a sudden two seconds.
That's when I'm a very big
outspoken advocate of, hey,
you should have some dedicated
resources on your team,
either learn about R
and Shiny or, if this
is a problem that you
think could be scaled
for the entire
business, then consider
submitting some
type of intake form
so that other business
units could also make
use of this type of Shiny app.
Thank you.
I see a lot of great
questions coming in.
And I really like the way
you describe the open culture
at Centene and it being
OK to ask questions,
but also providing that
time back to people
and being so willing to help.
I see Libby, you had asked a
question about the community
at Centene, I believe.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah, I would love to.
So I hope I'm not
remembering incorrectly,
but I'm pretty sure you
had a hand in starting
R user group at Centene when
you were there previously.
And so I was
wondering if you could
talk a little bit about
that, because that's
a difficult task.
And you have to recruit
people, and getting people
to meet up and help each
other and stuff like that
is really challenging.
So I was hoping
you could give us
a little bit of a rundown
on how that happened.
Yeah.
Thanks, Libby, and
great to see you.
So I sort of piggybacked from a
general data science community
chat that we had at the company.
And there were
several hundred people
on this of varying backgrounds
and expertise levels.
And so there was a lot of
conversation happening.
There was already a Python
group that was meeting--
I think every other month.
So me coming in, three
weeks after I started,
I got really excited
about the possibility
of potentially creating
something similar for R users.
And so I think it
started by just trying
to figure out who owns that
already existing data science
chat and see if they could help
support the idea of creating
an R user group, something
to meet once a month or once
every two months.
Because I think at
the larger companies,
getting that type of top-level,
executive stamp of approval
and support can go a long way,
especially if that individual
is part of the already existing
IT or data science function.
And so yeah, at the time,
I created a Blogdown site.
For those of you who are
familiar with R Markdown,
Blogdown, it's a
package that allows
you to create static websites,
static blogs with R Markdown.
Distill is a very
similar concept.
Quarto, now with Quarto,
you can do the same thing,
creating websites.
And yeah, I love the
syntax of Quarto.
But anyway, I think what started
as 13 users the first month,
one of them is at RStudio now.
I don't know if he's on
this chat, Dave Gruenewald.
He might be here.
Anyway-- Hey, Dave.
Hey, I'm here.
Hey.
Thanks, Jav.
How are you?
Yeah, so Dave--
DAVID GRUENEWALD: Doing great.
Dave taught me Shiny.
I tell him this often, I owe
my current career to Dave.
Because Shiny itself
made me such a better
overall programmer.
And the way I think
about functions
and recycling code,
seriously, thank you, Dave.
But yeah, what started
with about 13 users
within a few months
jumped to about 100,
125 monthly users that were on
this R-specific monthly meetup.
So we had a really great time.
The partnerships
we had with Posit,
we were able to get some people
to come in and do workshops
as well.
Everyone was so collaborative.
And it was such a
great way to see
the excitement around what
you could do with all things
R and even Python.
Like, how can we
into these robust
Python libraries or Python?
And we had reticulate
sessions, where
it was a co-branded
Python, R kind of workshop.
We're looking at ways
in which we can actually
communicate between teams
of different languages
a lot easier.
And so, anyway, I had a
great experience with it.
That's awesome.
Thank you.
I see a few
anonymous questions I
want to make sure to
jump over to as well.
And one was, how do you
navigate stakeholder uncertainty
and incongruent
project valuations
for data science projects versus
more traditional engineering
projects?
That's a good question.
I don't know about traditional
engineering projects,
to be honest.
I don't feel like I've been
surrounded by that world enough
to speak--
yeah.
I really don't know.
When it comes to the data
science projects, at least
at the point I feel
like where we are now,
just really careful, objective,
unbiased review of what the ask
has been very helpful,
being able to--
and however way you
want to do this,
it doesn't need to
be just dollar value.
Like, what savings
are we going to have?
Or, what benefits
You can kind of score the
different potential projects
coming in, where, at
least project to project,
you can prioritize which one
is going to have the most
impact for the business.
An impact can even be
measured differently, like,
which one is going to have
the most short-term impact?
What's the best project
for long-term impact?
Maybe all these things
could be different weights
for your scoring of
these different projects
to understand what your
team should focus on.
But yeah, I would say trying
to develop some system
or framework where
you can actually
help prioritize or
rate the importance
of these new projects
is really helpful.
Thank you.
There's actually a followup
anonymous question to that too.
And I'm going to start just
copying the Slido questions
into the chat so
people can see them
as I'm reading them as well.
But the question was, what
does an ROI timeline look
like for most projects?
Are you working on things
that come to life years
down the line?
I actually do not know yet.
But I would say, a lot
of these probably come
to life within the same year.
Yeah.
I don't think the
planning is so far ahead.
There are larger IT goals
and things in motion
that could be a multi-year
type of transition.
I just don't work on
those types of projects.
The focus of my work is
more data-science specific.
Thank you.
Jared, I see you asked
a question in the chat.
Do you to jump in live?
Yeah.
Can you guys hear me OK?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yes.
Awesome.
So yeah, I guess for
me, it's more like,
I can relate in a heavy way
to the one-off background
to what you're doing.
And so a lot of the obstacles
I've always tried to overcome
is just applying my particular
skill set in programming
to the work that I'm doing.
But having more of like a
medical and epi background
has been a huge
benefit to me but is
something that is often lost in
translation to leadership or to
[AUDIO OUT].
Did we lose Jared,
or was that me?
No, I think we lost him.
Jared, you froze.
Well, I'm sure Jared will
be back in a few seconds.
Do you get the sense
of the question?
Let's wait a second.
We'll jump to one so
Jared can hear the answer.
Let me jump over
to one from Slido,
and then we'll go back to Jared.
OK, yep.
But the question was,
you've got epidemiologists
and biostatisticians in your
organization, as in pharma.
Do you see any change from
those folks using some--
I get it-- some
alternative software to R?
That's good, right?
Yeah.
I work in a mostly
Python-dominated world.
Most of my colleagues
are Python users.
From an object-oriented
programming perspective,
there is a lot that is
going on on a daily basis
that they're working on, which
is more traditional engineering
related, not specific to
data science or inference
or prediction.
I am a huge believer that
you should use whatever
you feel most competent in.
If you feel restricted
by a certain technology,
like if you feel restricted
by some alternative software,
you can start exploring
R or Python or Julia.
You'd probably want to
start with whatever's
most closely aligned
with the syntax
so that it doesn't
feel like you're
having to pull your
hair out while you're
trying to work a full business
day and learn a new language.
But yeah, I'd say SAS comes
with a heavy price tag.
The sooner you can become
comfortable or find a way
to replicate the
same type of work
with an open-source
programming language,
you might find yourself
able to do things just
as fast and with maybe
a more robust skill
set or capabilities
with the language
to visualize or iterate
or make predictions.
Thanks, Javier.
I'm worried about Jared now.
He's not back yet.
So we'll hold Jared's question.
So I was actually going
to try and figure out
how to work this into
the conversation,
because I love this
example when you share it.
And somebody asked
anonymously, did you
create a branded test Shiny
app in applying for your return
to Centene?
No, I didn't.
Luckily, I had several
apps in production.
We were doing some
really neat things
when I was at Health Net.
So we had several apps
that were in production.
It got to the point
where managing
some of the pipelines
for the different apps
was becoming a bit
of a recurring, more
time-consuming process.
The more apps we
had, all of a sudden,
we found ourselves
needing to continue
to streamline data intake
or transformation for some
of these different apps.
And so we created
a web app updater
that, it was itself a
Shiny app but also capable
of updating other
Shiny apps or at least
the code from other Shiny apps.
It's not typical to see that
kind of stuff with Shiny apps,
at least not the
Shiny apps I've seen.
So anyway, where I was going
with this, the production
team I am now part of, or
the corporate data science
team, at least they
had some samples
to chew off of
the type of R work
that our Shiny work
that I could do.
But I would say for
organizations not familiar
with Plotly Dash apps or
Streamlit apps or Shiny apps,
being able to show
them the speed of a web
application like Shiny
and how clean it can look
with an advanced UI, that
definitely goes a long way,
in my opinion, to impressing
the people that you
were interviewing with.
For anybody who
didn't see it before,
didn't know what that
question was referencing to,
Javier had shared before that
in an interview with Bloomreach,
he created an interactive Shiny
app that used their branding
and color scheme.
And so I just put
that into the chat
too so everybody
can see the blog
post that he made about that.
Yeah, Travis Geerke--
I don't know if
he's on here today.
But he had asked if
he could reference
this as a cover letter accessory
in one of his R conf talks.
And I was like, of course,
yeah, please do this.
But at the time, my
GitHub repository for it
was just a super
high-level readme.
It was Oh, this, is a Shiny app
that I styled with Bloomreach.
Blogdown So I wrote
this blog post just
in an effort for people that
are less familiar with Shiny
or maybe with R, I tried
to write it in a way
where people with basic
git or GitHub understanding
could go in there
and clone the repo
and try and tweak the app to
their liking, to their company.
I'd love to just
put it out there,
if anybody else has
other apps that you
think would be really helpful to
share with examples like this,
feel free to put them into the
chat too so we can all see.
I love to see all the
resources shared in the chat.
Jumping-- oh, you go.
I was just going to say,
Appsilon as well, they're
a consulting firm, data
science consulting firm.
They make some
incredible Shiny apps.
They have some beautiful Shiny
app examples on their gallery,
on their public-facing website.
The Shiny website itself--
I don't know what the new
Posit link for it is--
but that has a bunch examples
on their gallery with both.
You can go in there and
launch the Shiny app.
You can also see the
source code behind each
and every one of those.
So that's a good
way to learn too.
Sorry, Rachael,
cut you off there.
No, this is your show.
I want you to share everything.
I was trying to just share some
of those links into the chat
there too.
But, Jared, I see you're back.
Can you hear us?
JARED WOOLFOLK: Yes.
Hopefully, I'm not cutting out.
Sorry, the weather
here is terrible, but--
No, no worries.
We can hear you now.
JARED WOOLFOLK: OK,
short and sweet--
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: We wanted
to make sure to not answer
your question when
you dropped off,
so let's circle back
to the beginning.
JARED WOOLFOLK: OK.
So short and sweet, just wanted
to get your opinion on if grad
school was the way to go to
getting you to feeling like you
were able to open up the
doors for more data science
and machine-learning type
roles, or if having that one-off
background--
I mean, ideally, for me, I
come from kind of a hybrid.
My background is more
in public health epi.
But then I do more programming
and clinical-type work.
But having that heavy
medical background
has always been an asset.
So I didn't know,
from your background,
if you felt that was the way
to get your feet in the door
or if you were more--
was it a benefit, or
do you feel like you
could have got there without,
I guess is the short answer.
Grad school
allowed me the time
to be able to get to where I
wanted with the basics of data
science and programming.
If I was in a full-time
job throughout that time--
you know what?
Even if I didn't
have a full-time job,
I think grad school just gave
me a set routine for being
able to learn this stuff.
I don't actually think
you need a graduate degree
to get into this type of work.
I lack the discipline to learn
all these topics and concepts
just on my own.
And for me, I found
that grad school really
did help just push me
to learn, not Python R,
more specifically, to learn
about the math that underpins
a lot of the data science
that we're doing now
and how to apply these
different algorithms to business
problems.
The way in which grad
school sort of force
feeds that information to
you, I think the alternative,
learning on your own
would just be really hard.
I don't know that there's
any one resource that--
and I'm sure there are
some great ones out there.
I just don't know of
any sole resource that
would give you such a robust or
holistic understanding of data
science.
I hope that answers
your question, Jared.
JARED WOOLFOLK: Yeah, no,
I think it really does.
There's so much to learn.
And it's kind of like trying to
stay ahead of a moving train.
And it always makes
me curious to know--
your I it's not a
one size fits all,
but like the right
approach to learning
this versus trying to just
ingest such large amounts,
like consistency, like you said
and holding yourself personally
accountable to train
yourself through that
but just knowing
and understanding
if there's a better way.
Yeah, no, I get it.
Yeah, for me, I kind of knew
the kinds of data science
work I wanted to get into.
I was doing--
I wasn't calling
it this-- but I was
doing time-series forecasting.
That was sort of my bread and
butter in financial modeling.
And so I knew of all these
different techniques for time
series that were possible.
I just didn't know
where to start.
And so grad school
for me really helped
sort of open the doors of
what's possible with code
for different types of
time series problems.
I see, Hugh, you
asked a great question
in the chat a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah, sure.
I first want to say
thank you to Javier.
I've been super
excited for this talk.
And he's had a number of
kind comments on LinkedIn
and chats in the past.
And I've always been really
appreciative of his willingness
to engage like that.
So thank you, this is awesome.
I wanted to ask with you
standing up in R group
and potentially converting
people, when you're showing
somebody R for the first time
that they may potentially
move over, what are
some of the things
that you focus on,
i.e., the visualization
aspects or the
cleaning transformation
side of modeling?
I know oftentimes, it feels like
the consumers of the products
are really excited
about the visuals.
But the day-to-day
people get more
excited about the
quality-of-life things
and the ease of working
with data, so just curious
if you had any insights on that.
I think where I've had
the most success is less
so on the end-to-end consumers,
who might be looking at a Shiny
app or some type
of visualization,
and more on the people
generating the numbers
or summaries that might later
turn into a visualization
or some type of Shiny app.
And so with that, where I
feel like I've had the most
success with teams that are
using SAS or Excel is really
with just the data-manipulation
capabilities of something
like R.
Firstly, the tidyverse,
which has grown so much,
but the idea of a unified syntax
for data handling and just
showing them the basics
of dplyr and tidyr,
like, this is how you group
by one or many variables.
This is how you
can do a summation.
This is how you create
new columns of sums.
Here's your summary data.
This is how, using
tidyr, this is
how I can pivot really
wide or really long.
Or maybe you need to do both
for a certain calculation.
Showing them the speed in
which this could be done
has always really
impressed people.
That's where I've
had the most success.
It's kind of the basics
of these things, not even
the really advanced
topics or concepts.
Yeah.
Awesome, thank you.
Yeah, the pivoting is always
where people go, what?
For me.
[LAUGHS] But thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Another question in the
chat I see is from John.
Do you want to jump in next?
Nope, not yet.
So it is, you went from Excel
to a lead machine learning
engineer, can you tell us about
the journey, anything you found
surprisingly hard or easy?
Because of SQL, I had a
really good understanding
of at least how tabular
data could be joined.
And the different
transformations
that could be done to
these data objects.
I think I would have
really struggled
without that basic
understanding.
But having said that, I think
the parts where I really
struggled at first
was function writing.
Function writing was
not intuitive to me.
Basic function writing was.
But in general, I found
it to be very complicated.
And it took a
solid, I don't know,
three to six months of practice
to feel actually comfortable
function writing.
Even when I started
building Shiny apps--
basic Shiny is quite easy.
But large functions underpin
the entirety of a Shiny app.
Everything you do within
Shiny is effectively
writing functions.
So the process of learning
Shiny and becoming
more comfortable with
Shiny was very difficult
and something that just
took a lot of repetitions.
But it all sort of
played together.
Because while Shiny, people
think of it more as a frontend
type of system, it did make
me a much better programmer
in the way I thought
about actual functions
and function writing.
Other things that I
found hard, looking back,
I'm sort of embarrassed
to say this,
but reproducibility
of machine learning
was not something
super intuitive either.
Like, being able to
reproduce a code set
and get the exact same
predictions every time,
I wasn't quite sure
why this wasn't working
or how to create these
fixed views, setting a seed
or whatever you need to do
to ensure that someone else
downstream could replicate
your study or analysis and get
the exact same
findings themselves.
Yeah.
I hope that's what you
were looking for, John.
Thanks, Javier.
And somebody had
asked anonymously
on Slido, what ID,
if any, are you
and your colleagues using for
development work, RStudio,
emacs, vim, VS Code, Notepad?
I think all of
the above, honestly.
Yeah.
I use RStudio every day.
So I'm in the RStudio IDE.
I seem to be in terminal
a lot these days, just
like the show, writing
bash commands and whatnot.
Anyway, but yeah,
the RStudio IDE,
definitely where I
spend most of my time.
I know that you are two
weeks into this new role.
But if you think of the next
year ahead in this role ,
what are you most excited about?
Or what made you most
excited about this role?
For me, it was more--
I'm really excited about
the challenge that's
going to come with becoming a
better just overall software
engineer or become better at
programming at large, not just
R specific.
I'm constantly humbled
at everyone I work with,
just their breadth
of knowledge with all
these different systems.
I've touched a lot of
these different systems
for ML ops or ML engineering.
But being able to
really dive deeper
into some of these platforms
to get production jobs out
of any language, I'm really
excited about the challenge
there and the growth and
learning opportunity.
Thank you so much, Javier.
And I know we have
five minutes left
because you do have a meeting
at the top of the hour here.
So I want to make sure that
there weren't questions
that I missed over on
Slido or through the chat.
I just happened
to see a question.
It said, anyone using
VS Code for R Shiny?
I've tried this.
I still feel like
RStudio itself is just
the gem for coding
in R. But I do really
like VS Code for Python.
DANIEL PATTERSON:
Thanks, Javier.
You This is Daniel.
I asked that question.
I asked it because I write a
lot of R in my position as well,
and I write a lot of
Shiny applications.
And I've started to
think about VS Code
because I write my Python
and PostgreSQL in VS Code,
and I just like all
that to be together.
But as you mentioned,
VS Code is not ideal
for R. And RStudio really is
the best place for writing
our code these days.
And I'm just kind of wondering
what your others are in that.
Yeah, yeah.
I see a few
comments in the chat
too, Daniel, on
different perspectives.
And in the minute, few minutes
or so we have left here,
I know there were a lot of
questions in the beginning
and comments on Excel
and data science.
And I was just
curious, circling back
to that conversation,
what do you think
has been most effective
for you at bridging
the gap between those two
teams or two sets of users?
Because I know there are
some people who are probably
always going to stay
in Excel, but you might
need to work with them as well.
And what have you found helpful?
If you're working at a company
that's large enough where--
it doesn't need to
be a large company.
But I feel like at
larger companies,
tapping into databases--
or you actually have databases.
You're not just
operating in a world
where it's Excel
files or CSV files.
Then showing how you could
stay within the same R notebook
or framework from
data collection,
just pulling it straight
into your environment,
manipulating it
there, writing it out
or summarizing it
as an HTML file,
like knitting an
RMD to an HTML file
or a flexdashboard
or something that's
still static but interactive,
that has gone a long way too.
And the speed of
everything, the speed
of the data manipulation and
data handling for millions
or tens or hundreds
of millions of rows,
that always shocks people.
Because if you've got a lot of
columns in Excel, after about,
I don't know, 3,000 or 4,000
rows, your Excel is crawling.
And you can look at your
RAM, and it's eating up
your entire available RAM.
Whereas with something
like Python or R,
it's definitely not the case.
Thank you.
I was scrolling
the chat and I see
a lot of people weighing in with
comments on talking people out
of PhDs and suggesting
that as a topic idea.
But, Javier, before
you go, I know
in the beginning
you also mentioned
one of the things you like to
do for fun is keeping up to date
on everything that's going
on in the data science space.
And I was curious if there
are other resources or maybe
people you follow
or things that you'd
like to share with us all.
Let's see.
The tidyverse blog,
in terms of staying up
on news related to tidy models
or tidyverse, that's great.
That's one of my
favorite resources.
The RStudio AI blog, or Posit AI
blog, that's another good one,
just looking at the incremental
developments with Torch, which
is like, native Torch
for R and then looking
at Luz, which is like
the Keras for Torch.
That stuff really excites me.
Twitter has been amazing.
So keeping up on Twitter
with a lot of the R-related R
stats or Shiny or other
sort of hashtags like that,
that's been a great resource.
The R Bloggers, or R Weekly--
R Weekly is a great publication.
You can subscribe to
their XML and just
get a weekly download
of new packages,
new updates to existing
packages, new tutorials.
Eric Nance runs the
R Weekly podcast.
He's one of the cohosts there.
Yeah, there's just a plethora
of resources out there.
Awesome.
Thank you so much, Javier,
for joining us and sharing
your insights this
week, but also
in other weeks as well when
you're on the audience side.
I did want to let everybody
know-- because this comes up
sometimes, as there's
great comments
and resources in the chat.
You can save the chat.
So the little three dots
to the righthand corner,
if you press that, you
can save the chat too.
But I will try and group them
to share with the recording
when it goes up to
the site as well.
Thanks, Rachael.
Yeah, if anyone
wants to contact me,
feel free to hit
me up on LinkedIn.
It's probably the best place--
Twitter as well, but I
don't use Twitter as much.
Awesome.
I know you have to
jump, so no worries
if you have to leave us here.
I'm going to share your
LinkedIn in the chat as well.
All right, great.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, thank you, and hope to
see everybody back next week.
We will be joined next week
by JJ Allaire, CEO and founder
of RStudio, now Posit.
Maybe he heard that,
as he's walking
by here, but excited to talk
with JJ next week as well.
And that will be our
last hangout for 2022.
It's so nice to see
you all this week.
Have a great rest of the day.